[Music]
Tim when Joe walked in this morning how
did you greet him I greeted him by
clicking our feet together China hi I
said I said mija me how he hung no
that's what they're doing now in China
it's the this no hands yeah no dance no
I'm telling is the corona shake why
can't they just stick to bowing they
don't bow anymore huh Japanese people
they don't bow no more what about just a
head Bob people didn't handshake he
become kind of a thing I thought Chinese
people were like [ __ ] that we're calming
is winking about no more yeah they
invented the yeah Confucius did you do
this they invent is about and then
they're like let's get this thing out of
here
what come on man [ __ ] with man yeah but
if they're from Wuhan it's you can [ __ ]
with them yeah
dangerous they don't [ __ ] with them all
right but they'll [ __ ] with you know you
you can't [ __ ] with you can't [ __ ] with
them no if they're from alone you cannot
follow time yeah well yeah so the reason
we're talking about it's cool yeah this
handshake thing went viral that's what I
saw I liked this one man that guy lives
in a big-ass van that's a big ass that's
a small tire for a big it looked like
Amazon yeah why don't they do that here
you go
don't you Oh tired yeah that's pretty
cool yeah it's pretty cool hey that's
kind of friendly me and Tim did that
this morning too
it's fun to do with you you did
as though I like that unless you're they
bow and Iran that's cool that seems kind
of fun I'm too lazy so just want to do
one kind of like the French how they do
like two kisses but in Mexico you just
do one or if you're if you're a more is
on our train and she's leaving you like
or you go these are brand new Ashley
wait wait alright there a black football
player if I come up with some [ __ ]
sick [ __ ] it's complicated handshake
he's always like that's true like this
yeah that's always like that [ __ ] tight
I can't memorize it though almost over
I know I think and I have tried making
our own handshake so many times a week
and never how often do they practice
that it's got to just get into the
pattern
yeah me and she had one for like a month
what what is it what was it it was like
one of these and came in one of these
and then end it with than it ended with
ended up with that do you like a drink
yeah a problem
we got alcohol if you feel bad be great
if your secret handshake was like it's
like we do this and then I grab my keys
I had I head out you head out to work
and then we drive through our separate
places but this is all part of the
handshake oh my god phone at work doing
your thing and like whatever you do talk
to your boss all that [ __ ] it's all part
of the handshake yes the same thing
hi routine and then you come home and
just close it out with like a I'm taking
that I'm taking all day it's a secret
handshake
my boy used to have this dope and Shh to
love it what's this uh okay what we're
gonna do is want to shake we're gonna
count to five in our heads not say
anything and then in the handshake all
right since what we do like set you know
they call this DAPs now yeah that's is
just is that's what we called it
yeah but now it's like oh but now
they're like hey can I give you Depp's
and I'm like what's what do you mean
like they're like oh we go like this
that's at that and I'm like we invented
that [ __ ] what are you why do you mix
up the word adapt is a digital app what
would this called in the path mr. Shaikh
I call the a slide pound even when I was
in high school like people in my high
school called listen I thought this act
was that be same I thought it's like yo
this is not the DAP can we get legal
council here to figure out what it is
isn't this morning this one no not not
twice travolta but you know what twenty
years I had to teach I had to teach Chia
cuz she would always be confused
watching me shake hands with people and
I was to tell her I'm like okay so
usually it's like this well this is how
it was in my high school right shake
hands with a Mexican dude it was like
this it was slide pound right shake
hands with the black dudes the homies it
was like uh with little bit of
resistance resistance on this and that's
licking and then man there was white
boys a little tricky that's like
something like this one know why boys
like boys it tends to be a this and then
into a and I always ask them because I
never know I'm like always snapping or
pounding are we snapping you're
battening sometimes just being both yeah
you know I always do I'm like
I what we doing we snapping a pound snap
upon it's never bad all right cool
you always feel so uncool when you don't
know what's happening though my boxing
coach yours does this two times right
like this
and so that's why i'm used to every time
i see it or after practice two times
like this i haven't seen him for like
three months so do the two times to me
you wanted a straight-up hug but i'm
still trying to do like the second time
yeah he's coming up and hug your [ __ ]
saluting it and I might get I'm hugging
him and I'm kinda like behind this
background like I thought we'd do it two
times
we're always do a two time it so just
wants to know it's him he's [ __ ]
being awkward right now oh that's
awkward did cuz this book because once
you get used to even have to look
anymore right right
yeah the Louvre they already already
it's that's how comfortable I got and at
this time I was at all it's my country
get on now here's the best right here
here's how you make it real awkward
episodes they go all right that's it
yeah
keep this simple yeah something girls I
have to worry about we just hug yeah
yeah it's easy
hey girl I never know what I never know
what kind of guy I'm about to handshake
or hug or whatever the [ __ ] I'm guys do
that [ __ ] where it's like they do this
[ __ ] when you come up to them and then
they Basin impersonal is that Brazilian
I don't know where it's from must be an
Ohio thing I think it's [ __ ] rude I
find it very rude it's the endianness
shake yeah
you ever do this you'll do this one
where you are jellyfish and they're like
ah I think I'm my bad my bad coming for
the hug
big jellyfish oh my god take that to
your parties guys you know what people
started doing to instead of this they'll
go BAM like they'll slap your pounds
yeah yeah yeah yeah I've seen that this
is so much more fun to talk about than
Corona oh yeah dude la la County state
of emergency just happened are we
talking about Quran today though this is
us talking about Corona yeah okay so
yesterday do many Corona news is gonna
get Corona saturated cuz last week was
Corona everything was everything but you
didn't know much more has happened since
last week right they just updated the
[ __ ] figures and it's it's now 3%
people can die instead of like being
what was it people thought it was you
said - in the past 3% closing everything
and canceling everything yeah they might
not do the Olympics yeah jahmai after
the Olympics and also I did not know
this I got this wrong last time the the
flu is like point whatever the [ __ ] 2%
chance of dying when you have the flu
please you know what [ __ ] tens of
millions of people got the flu last year
but the amount of people that died was
like 0.2% of that right so when you have
corona it's actually 34 times worse I
heard something like that this morning
so yeah so so if the flu kills 0.2%
Coronas killing 3% so that's that's a
big number but what the good news seems
to be so far that it's it's relatively
small as far as like it's not ten
percent of the people dying three
percent is a pretty good rate it's not
as bad as how SARS was how about the
percent of catching it that's the scary
part right because if you're talking
about three percent of the world's
population that's millions of people and
what's crazy are the health
professionals that are dying what is it
there's people the doctors and wuhan a
lot of those guys are dying - exactly
I'm like if you're a doctor and you and
you know everything about this how the
[ __ ] are you dying yeah the 90 everybody
could buy that isn't
dear old lady that [ __ ] yeah she can
do it we can do she can be hey we can
beat it yeah people can beat it for sure
but that's what's good that's the good
news
she might also be so old we're like it's
like fly landing on moldy bread I'm
texting Joe as soon as I walk in well
first of all parking was [ __ ] nuts
and I got that like 11 a.m. I wasn't
there to panic about anything I was just
going to get regular [ __ ] yeah
everyone's buying Arrowhead water yeah
they're all filling up toilet paper and
Arrowhead water yeah why is that it was
always you're gonna be like on house
arrest well why is it toilet paper and
air but they don't they don't want to
leave your house and canned foods so
they think people are just gonna be
confined or houses in the [ __ ] goes
crazy [ __ ] tons of people are buying
bottled water that tells me people don't
have filtered water I have a filter I
have to because I'm like how wasteful
are you they're thinking it's gonna get
into the system and the corona you're
gonna get into the waters it's gonna get
through my Britta I don't think so I
think you know how this I'm not writing
the news bro I just deliver got white
people panicking because I was like why
are they buying all the water do people
not have like a water system next to
their sink when people hear emergency or
state of emergency they they go into
like if there was a hurricane right now
or tornado whatever is like what do you
want to get I'm at this like point right
now where I'm kind of like weary I'm
like oh oh because our mover he was
coffee manage all of our shape I'm like
why do you not cover your mouth with the
Asian know he was like Russian here I
feel safe for a little bit does get
those [ __ ] disinfectant wipes and
just do go to go over yeah if he's
Russian it's probably just bronchitis
yeah from smoking mask you know I know
it's crazy to kill a few were exhausting
a lot of energy they were sweating like
they were really tired and they only
wanted to drink soda really there's
water and they're like no soda no [ __ ]
that [ __ ] I am Russian I'm like no
wonder you guys are so sick or at least
that one guy was sick but I don't know
like I've never thought of like
let me stay away from this person that's
really really sick you're like I don't
know I've never really been that
precautious but now with [ __ ] going like
this on my go [ __ ] wash your hands a lot
and drink a lot of soda that's for me
[Music]
[Music]